Mình bởi thống bởi, giờ trước Phà Khi Stang sắc nhận ít nhất Hamilbain người đã
sâu vụ sập một toa chung cư năm tần trước lỗi và ngày tại đủ thị đông dần nhất cả nước
caraci tham hoạc của khiến dưới trước phải sau tàn hàng trăm người khác trong ma phò nhà lần cất
giò lòng ngại mất ăn toàn. Gián tiếp đẩy thêm hàng chục người vào cảnh xin sống tà bởi
trước lỗi kư dân cho biết, phò nhà dục lắc dưới dội trước khi đột sập vui lấp tọn độ một trong người
từ mấy hai gia đình bên trong những khối bây tông và rất thách đổ nát.
Như nạn nhất là dân là đồng giao thuộc cốc đồng thiệu số hoặc dân dịch gư không có sự lợi
trọng xin sống ở những người an toàn mà buộc phải trọng toàn nhà của ký lạng đời chuan.
Họ giờ đây thêm khoang mang lâu lắng cho tựng lai khi mất nhà cửa và tại sản.
Chính quyền địa phương caraci của Phà Khi Stang cho biết toàn nhà trước khi video sập đã tự được
có qua trước năng yêu cầu sơ tán yêu lần từ những năm 2018, gần nhất là vào cuối thẳng sấu năm 2019.
Hẹn chứa địa phương cộng tức tóc đến hành kìm chà năm 2018, tựng tư để ngăn chạp thảm hoạc sây ra.
Công tắc ký hồ ký thúc tối một sò tháng bây sau bà ngày tìm kìm trong độ đồn á.